[Musique]
monsieur bonjour nous vous interview
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle singer view nous avons voulu
vous recevoir car vous occupez
actuellement une pause un poste de
syndicalistes et surtout vous travaillé
dans la police et vous travaillez dans
quel type de police et quel type de
syndical je vous écoute désolé pour la
question et je vous écoute donc je
travaille donc pour la cgt police je le
secrétaire général depuis quelques mois
et sinon je travaille dans un service
d'enseignement qu'est le service des
territoires et du renseignement
territoriales mais celui qui a pris la
suite des renseignements généraux
d'accord on va vous faire une question
qu'a simple donc grade matricule alors
alexandre langlois gardiens de la paix
et matricule 135 793 gardiens de la paix
pourquoi gardiens de la paix dans le
renseignement
parce que déjà pas au pgi à l'europe et
jean ont dans leur région officier de
police judiciaire exactement dans le
renseignement territoriales comme chez
les anciens rg tous les collègues qui
travaillait là n'avaient pas leur
qu'elle perde et leur qualification de
pj mais on ne peut pas l'avoir pour
faire une distinction entre
administratif et judiciaire à
l'exception du temps des rg avait une
petite exception sur les courts séjours
alors ça consiste en quoi le travail de
renseignement territoriale enseignement
territoriale donc on a repris 90% des
missions d'hergé qui consiste à dire
faire un baromètre social un petit peu
pour l'état et le but démission c'est de
prévoir tous les ce qui pourrait
troubler l'ordre public tout vous prenez
la température en face de la température
donc sur les manifestations si nous qui
comptons avec une petite anecdote pour
les collègues parisiens qui des fois y'a
une différence dans les chiffres par
exemple ils comptent pas les
manifestants sur les trottoirs qui sont
que des passants dans les autres
départements c'est plus facile mais je
vais vous dire je vous dire sur le
comptage des manifestants maintenant on
est à l'ère du numérique qui est grâce à
cette nouvelle loi
séquence avec la loi de programmation
militaire mais à la loi de la loi de
renseignements vous pouvez compter les
le nombre de téléphones portables sur la
zone donc qu'est ce que je peux vous
poser comme question concernant votre
travail à l'heure actuelle est-ce que
c'est difficile d'être syndicaliste
surtout travaillant dans l'enseignement
territorial are ça dépend quel syndicat
j'ai gardé beaucoup de syndicalistes qui
se recase après leurs quatre
syndicalistes il retourne au service
s'ils prennent un service d'enseignement
général présente dans mon service j'ai
eu des collègues qui sont venues du
syndicat unité sgp par exemple ou imiter
ou alliance qui sont arrivés ici après
leur mandat syndical
j'ai fait démarche inverse j'étais dans
service et je suis devenu du
syndicalisme parce que je n'avais pas
les moyens de travailler pourquoi vous
n'avez pas les moyens prévus alors je
suis allé au moment de la réforme juste
après la réforme des rg on était
informations générales à l'époque et
monsieur sarkozy quand celui-ci sarkozy
qui a lancé ça en 2008 l'énergie ont
disparu en juillet 2008 et où je ne suis
plus frais un mois près
et donc la réforme ce qui s'est passé
c'est que le
l'information générale à l'époque déjà
perdu le type de renseignements pour
faire informations ce qui est déjà une
dégradation dans le sentix dans la
sémantique et ensuite les missions sont
restés à 90% pour l'information générale
et 10% son parti fusionné avec la dst
pour créer la dcr ici sachant que les
moyens sont partis à 60 voire 70 % avec
les 10% des collectes coup rejoint là
des séries du coup les parents pauvres
les parents pauvres ayant plus de ça
nous étions une direction indépendante
et nous sommes passés sous la coupe de
la sécurité publique qui est un peu le
fourre-tout de la police nationale ce
qui fait que les objectifs sont pas les
mêmes et le moyen de travailler ne sont
pas les mêmes et que les quelles
difficultés aux grandes difficultés
concrètes c'est on n'a pas de véhicule
en nombre suffisant quand on a commencé
on était trois par véhicule c'était pas
terrible mais encore ça pouvait aller au
fur et à mesure on a eu des
renforcements nombre de personnel mais
pas en nombre de véhicules à l'heure
actuelle menée par exemple moi je serai
sur 78 on est à quatre cinq
fonctionnaires par véhicule ce qui veut
dire que comme on se déplace c'est à un
ou deux il y en a trois qui ont des
trois ou quatre qui restent sur le
carreau bureau avec ce qui s'est passé
en plus récemment on a eu des coupures
internet ce qui fait que même quand on
est au bureau des fois on a eu pendant
24 heures une fois la coupure à la tête
on n'a même pas pu travailler
correctement donc laurent c'est bien
dans territoriale ne fait que de
l'acquisition de renseignements sur le
terrain pas sur internet alors
normalement le but c'était de notre
d'agro différence entre éclats des
séries qu'est devenu dg si c'est que
nous avons sur le terrain murrow
renseignement humain j'ai à dire c'est
que notre enseignement c'est pas d'aller
à vue faire oralement d espionnage par
écoutes téléphoniques poser des caméras
nous c'est d'avoir les personnes qui
nous dit qu'ils nous disent qu'ils nous
renseigne qui nuisent pas le côté
délation mais pardon je vais prendre un
exemple sur les manifestations
je suis du côté social comme une
manifestation qui est déclarée entre en
contact avec les organisateurs le côté
en face c'est à dire s'il y en a un
savoir un peu pour mettre un service
d'ordre approprié que jour des
manifestations tout se passe bien qu'on
ne dise pas par exemple il était
l'élément perturbateur qu'on puisse
écarter que la manifestation se déroule
correctement et qui est pas une mauvaise
image qui est donné donc ça c'est notre
rôle donc après ce qu'on peut voir ces
informations là quand on connaît les
syndicalistes et chefs d'entreprise les
élus qui pourront nous dire bah tiens
j'ai entendu parler qui aurait de tels
rassemblements telle manifestation
contact humain frais au tac juin voit la
même chose un petit peu pour le la
surveillance de l'islam de france et
enfin des revenus en général mais à
l'heure actuelle c'est l'islam de france
où les mâts et et surtout renforcer ou
ses contacts avec les responsables de
mosquées etc pour un recomptage la
température savoir les prêches qui se
disent savoir s'il ya pas d éléments qui
serait un petit peu dissidents ou kirwan
un petit court 10e non plus radicale
radical j'ai à dire pour que bord
puisque sfr faire un environnement et
savoir si elle dangerosité ou pas
toujours le principe de faire une limite
pour sécurité des citoyens et liberté
d'expression tient la corde
je voudrais savoir comment vous mettez
en oeuvre vous enquête et quels sont les
problèmes que vous ayez feutrée
hiérarchie pourrait vous poser ici c'est
sur des dossiers un petit peu politiques
financiers ou des choses comme ça à ce
que vous avez de temps en temps des
enquêtes court circuité par votre
hiérarchie
alors les enfin sur le niveau
renseignements les rg faisait de lui la
politique juste dans les années jusqu'en
1995 à partir de là ils ont les est
dessaisi du domaine politique ce qui
était un petit peu normal ça coupait ses
avantages et les gens en place au
détriment de l'opposition à chaque fois
donc ça ça a été terminé après cela les
dossiers peuvent être qu'en circuiter
c'est toujours les chiffres qu'on veut
entendre je vais prendre un exemple
pour la manif pour tous par exemple les
services de renseignement en tous les
cas sur le 78e annoncé un chiffre de
manifestants qu'elle est dépassée sur
paris ça a été corrigé par l'allergique
estimé que ça faisait trop de monde à
envoyer sur paris pour le 78 qui est
pourtant fin un département favorable à
mme x pour tous en général et du coup
ils ont baissé les chiffres lendemain le
figaro titrait en grosses erreurs les
renseignements carrie stone elle s'est
trompée sur les chiffres des manifs on
annonce beaucoup plus de manifestants qu
est-ce qui étaient là ont rayonné par le
gouvernement a minimisé les chiffres
donc ça ça a été et minimiser chief pour
éviter que la que la plaie prennent
conscience de tel ou tel type de
mouvement ou l'ampleur de tel ou tel
type de mouvement je pense que c'est
plus pour vous alors je pourrai pas
parler à la place des politiques mais en
tout cas c'est dans l'idée qu'on a nous
cause qu'on se fait en tant que collègue
sur le terrain c'est qu'on voit ça c'est
que c'est pour plus faire de
l'accompagnement de la politique du
gouvernement pour transformer les
chiffres dans ce qu'on veut plutôt que
de dire la vérité aux gens c'est pour ça
aussi clergé sont des fous étaient
malvenus ou passer par une idée qu'on
s'est fait pour eux ils ont été cassées
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas leur langue
dans leur poche il disait ce qui se
passait plutôt que ce qu'on voulait
politiques voulaient entendre c'est à
dire c'est se dire l'intégrité de leur
profession du moins de leur vocation les
pousser à dire la vérité à dire la
vérité au dessus et au bout d'un moment
ça déplaise je vais donner un exemple
concret pour qu'on parle sur comment on
peut manipuler les statistiques et les
chiffres c'est pas dans l'enseignement
c'était au niveau d'un une personne qui
a été interpellée par exemple a été
interpellé par un commissariat c'est
arrivé dans le nord de la france
interpellés ils ont marqué un bâton
traités ensuite par un autre service du
commissariat qui s'occupait plus
spécialement un autre bâton après ils
ont été récupérés par la police
judiciaire qui a remarqué un même bâton
dire que dans les statistiques la même
personne arrêtée une fois a compté trois
fois
donc ça c'est pour dire on a fait bien
de travail etc sur paris on a des
collègues qui se plaignent l'ordi faut
par exemple il ya trop de vols pas de
problème les dossiers des vols passent
en dessous et on traite les autres ce
qui a besoin mais c'est quand même bien
plus justement c'est la balade est
justement ce n'est pas qu'un n'a plus
c'est juste qu'ils sont traités après
donc le mois suivant quand les chiffres
sont bons on les remet dans l'autre sens
j'allais donner enfin j'ai d'autres
exemples quel type de problème vos
collègues vous vous rencontrez en
général est ce que
la police va bien brisebois mal pourquoi
la police va mal ce qui est une perte de
sens du métier bien beaucoup de
collègues qui sont rentrés en dire pour
caricaturer pour défendre la veuve et
l'orphelin qui sont venus là en disant
pour qui la liberté la justice qu'elle
général l'intérêt général qui existent
il faut des limites nos vies d'avoir des
limites pour le bien de tous et que
chacun puisse s'exprimer et puis vivre
en collectivité
malheureusement dans les faits c'est
plus à céder vraiment des vocations il
ya deux il ya eu déjà beaucoup de
vocations après ça va vraiment planqué
la barre récemment c'est pas des
planqués je dirais c'est qu'avec la
crise et la difficulté de trouver un
emploi il ya des collègues plus récent
qu'on passait plusieurs concours et
compris le premier qu'ils avaient réussi
après un autre travail pour qu'ils aient
la vocation qui est puisse avancer
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle on
est un peu sclérosé parce que ben on a
eu d'abord la politique du chiffre qui a
été mis en place donc que personne c'est
ou parce que ça fait du mal ça fait du
mal je mets un haut-fonctionnaire ce
qu'ils ont perdu un peu de leur libre
arbitre avant on avait un libre arbitre
à dire pour nos collègues qui met les
contraventions etc il pouvait adapter
soit dire à personne fallait pas faire
ça etc mais il n'était pas forcément la
contravention ou la mettait souvent ce
qu'ils espéraient plus de rôle
pédagogique il ya plus le rôle
pédagogique il est de moins en moins là
pour la simple raison c'est que
maintenant tout est informatisé il ya
plus le contact humain on veut pression
qu'on veut couper sa populaire la police
de sa population pour qu'ils aient plus
de contact donc on a eu la politique je
suis chiffres quasiment place par
chevènement est amplifié par monsieur
sarkozy avec une note qui était sorti
dans un journal à pau qui a été qu'on
peut encore trouver sur internet avec
des objectifs chiffrés l'époque en
disant par exemple 83 outrage à agent
c'était ce qui était le plus drôle c'est
que commence à voir à l'avant ce qu'on y
aura d'outragé à agent dans l'année donc
impossible donc on se dit en rigolant à
moins de les provoquer qu'est ce qu'on
fait donc ça c'était le côté ou
ridicule de la politique du chiffre à
laquelle on arrivait ensuite on a eu
les contraventions qui ont été géré par
informatique maintenance et on peut
faire des procès des contraventions qui
sont directement envoyées à un centre de
gestion sur rennes et toutes étapes en
informatique dire qu'on a pu le contact
avec la personne ah oui un petit côté
pédagogie même si on mettait la
contravention pour expliqué l'asa pour
telle raison telle raison maintenant ça
va on voit même pas la personne et en
plus ça pose un problème puisque
l'informatique dans la police nationale
dans l'administration générale et des
fois mal géré ce qui fait qu'il ya des
gens qui se plaignent d'avoir pillé ou
quatre mentions alors dit bah écoutez
vous faites à recommander à vos frais
pour vous nous expliquez vous l'avez
déjà payé avec la personne sanctionnée
qui a déjà fait un remake a fait amende
honorable qu'a payé ce cas devait on lit
expliquez-vous pour nous expliquer
pourquoi nous on voit on comprend bien
que la police va mal par le fait que ben
on sourit on supprime le contact humain
entre quelqu'un qui a pratiquement donné
sa vie pour l'intérêt général qui donne
sa vie ou son travail pour l'intérêt
général et le manque de contact on peut
comprendre ça se manifeste comment tous
les jours vous avez quoi vous avez des
dépressions avait des gens agressifs
vous avez quoi alors on a des
dépressions des burn out de plus en plus
donc c'est moi le plus en plus de plus
en plus je vaux et chiffres des chiffres
bien sûr 30 ans l'a repris les chiffres
qu'elle fait donc ils sont quittés sur
un site victime du devoir qui ce qui
s'appelle et qui a été repris donc on
peut retrouver sur un sociologue
caroff aussi une étude sur ce ballon du
sociologue bonjour je l'apprécié
et donc du coup le l'enquète montrent
que depuis 1981 il ya eu à peu près
mille quatre cent cinquante collègues
qui sont suicidés qui ont réussi à se
suicider en parle pas des tentatives de
suicide un qui sont encore plus
nombreuses et en parallèle on a mis le
chiffre suivant qui a eu à peu près 490
collègues qui sont morts du devoir dire
mort à cause des délinquants et de leur
mission dire que la souffrance au
travail a créé quasiment trois fois plus
de morts que des délinquants et même
qu'est ce que ça fait quand vous
apprenez qu'un collègue s'est suicidée
avec son arme de service mais déjà ça
fait toujours tout drôle on se dit
pourquoi on n'a pas pu l'éviter comment
c'est arrivé et en général c'est là où
il ya une incompréhension pareil un
fossé qui se creuse même au sein de la
police en général au delà archi a
toujours une enquête qui lie problèmes
personnels c'est pour ça c'est n'a rien
avec le travail et en fait on va pas
plus loin alors c'est lourd de
symbolique quand même de prendre son
arme de service pour se soumettre
une bastos dans le crâne d'un c'est
lourd depuis peu grâce au conseil d'état
maintenant c'est reconnu d'office
comme quoi c'est le service qui est
responsable mais c'est une bataille de
longue haleine et surtout c'est que bath
effectivement c'est souvent lié aux
conditions personnelles familiales mais
parce que l'emploi du temps avec les
policiers par exemple j'ai donné à nancy
de travail des policiers en général
travaille en quête de cirque ils ont
quatre jours travaillés deux jours de
repos quatre jours travaillés c'est
clair qu'ils ont un week-end sur six
dire qu'ils sont coupés pas de giffoni à
la vie familiale pas de l'associatif
possible pour aller faire du sport
régulièrement des années ces stations
est ce qu'il ya des suicides dans les
familles des policiers c'est à dire que
par exemple les gamins à l'école ne
voyons pas leurs parents sont en échec
social est ce que les femmes attendant à
la maison sont dépressifs à ce que vous
avez est ce que vous avez mené des
études là dessus est ce qu'il ya des
chiffres des statistiques sur les
répercussions de votre travail sur le
contexte familial
j'en ai pas je ne les ai pas vus j'ai
pas cherché en tous les cas sur par
rapport au sujet des conditions de
travail par contre on sait qu'en général
quand il ya de plus en plus de familles
maintenant porte plainte en tant que
partie civile quand il ya un collègue
qui suscite donc ça de ce côté-là ça
monte à une application et qu il ya des
choses qui bougent et que par exemple
une qu'à nice il ya un ou deux ans le
commissariat mais sur la classe et
c'était fait
cause personnelle problème rien à voir
et finalement enquête a été ouverte etc
à l'heure actuelle on est en train de se
dire que finalement c'était peut-être le
travail quand même qui était derrière un
autre cas où ça c'est un collègue qui a
eu par exemple avec son style de travail
il avait garde alternée pour son fils il
avait un mercredi et un samedi sur deux
enfin un week-end sur deux pardon ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'on lui a fait une
promesse d'un nouveau site de traquer
très bien que les collègues voudraient
bien qu'ils soient généralisées qui est
toujours travail deux jours de repos
trois jours de travail la semaine
suivante on inverse donc voilà donc ce
que le collectif est impeccable on lui
avait promis ça le deal thoracique de
travail il l'avait il était parfait où
elle son fils comme prévu dans le tour
de garde il a demandé à l'est dans un
autre service on y écoute tu manges à
peut-on pas noir tu retournes dans
l'ancien site de travail d'ici quelques
mois entre mai mais c'est dès que de
l'oral résultat des courses il voyait
plus son fils à part un week-end sur six
est encore quand ça tombait le week-end
il était de garde ce qui fait que son
fils bela dijoux de plus devoir pour
noël et du coup le collègue qu'est ce
qu'il a fait alors c'est malheureux il a
pris ils avaient ils avaient prévu
d'aller faire d'avoir il y avait une
soirée le soir il a pris une bouteille
la vue il a bu un petit peu il y a été
du coup me
enquête administrative pour le
sanctionner on va dire c'est un collègue
alcoolique non en fait il a pourquoi
l'administration fait pas l'effort du
raisonnement dernière alors vous êtes
policier vous êtes syndicaliste vous
cumulez mais vous êtes en train de nous
réconcilier avec les deux
les syndicats dans la police qu'est-ce
qu'ils font qu'il gardait mains dans les
poches
qu'est ce qu'ils font mais avec quel est
vraiment leurs actions pour aider leur
corporation
alors les syndicats de police on va
faire un petit historique très rapide à
la cgt police était le seul syndicat de
police en 1948 n'avait pas d'autre ça
posait un problème au niveau du
gouvernement parce que du coup les crs
les policiers qu'on y avait une
manifestation il disait bravo les
manifestants opposant les matraques ce
qui n'allait pas du tout aux pouvoirs en
place du coup ils ont fait rentrer la
cftc puis au fur et à mesure du temps
l'administration a divisé les personnels
en différents syndicats et en
différentes catégories de personnel donc
vos prisons mehdi syndicats par les
adjoints techniques les adjoints
administratifs les gardiens de la paix
les officiers les commissaires comme ça
tout le monde s'opposer dans tous les
sens impeccable du coup aussi donc
pourquoi en arriver là c'est ce que chez
nous les syndicats tiennent en fait un
peu le rôle jedir de drh c'est un peu
curieux c'est que tout ce qui est muté à
sion avancement on doit passer par le
syndicat pourquoi dans les textes il ya
des commissions administratives
paritaires ca paix et cesser ap sont
donc comme leurs noms l'indiquent moitié
admistration moitié syndicats elles ont
un rôle consultatif et à la base des
syndicats siégeait pour vérifier que la
distraction ne faisait pas n'importe
quoi au niveau des avancements et
mutations ça s'est transformé en
maintenant les syndicats choisissez un
peu qu'ils veulent et en échange ils
fichent la paix l'administration et ça
s'est retourné en fait si on connaît
quelqu'un dans un syndicat qui est bien
placé on aura notre avancement notre
mutation plus rapidement et si on n'est
pas dedans bal aura pas je parle des
syndicats majoritaires qui siègent
lesquels donc nous avons pour les
canapés unités gp est faux et de côté en
deux ans par l alliance qui est la cfe
cgc pour les officiers nous avons le c6
qui est ancien snop nathan ccq ce
qu'indique ad
faites de l'intérieur que j'ai plus le
nouveau nom on l'appelle toujours le
stop et synergie de l'autre côté qu'elle
pendant à la cfe cgc et les syndicats
des commissaires au dessus dont je
faisais un syndicat des commissaires la
police nationale syndicat indépendant
des commissaires de la police nationale
donc ça c'est la majoritaire et je joue
couple
on entend toujours dire que les
syndicalistes sont corrompus que les
syndicats sont corrompus ce ce bruit de
on dit toujours il n'ya jamais de fumée
sans feu vous avez entendu du côté des
syndicats de police des magouilles des
choses comme ça
moi je vais donner d'un exemple après je
vais pas porter de jugement un jugement
soi même nous avons eu donc par exemple
pour les officiers nous avons eu le
secrétaire général du syndicat synergie
qui s'était présenté sur les listes
provenir conseil général les listes ump
voilà à la fin il a été lui donc très
bien mais il ne pouvait pas cumuler les
deux mandats ce n'était pas possible
donc comme si t'es pas possible d'être à
la fois policier est à la fois sané
liévin la fois élu aux régionales
monsieur sarkozy l'a passée préfets
sous-préfets immédiatement pour pouvoir
concilier les deux un autre exemple nous
avons eu quelqu'un quand que vous a peut
être j tinto c'est à dire ça reste un
flic un préfet non après fait c'est un
préfet certains autres corps c'est un
autre côté la préfecture quelques
commissaires arrive dans le corps
préfectoral un saint mais c'est le rêve
les commissaires rêverait d'être intégré
dans ce corps là cirque c'est le corps
au dessus pour donc c'est pas ou si
c'est pas la même pièce et plus les pc
plus que tu n'es plus policier après à
d'autres les représentants de l'état
dans les départements
est un autre exemple donc toujours sur
le voir rester sur le corps préfectoral
le
niveau donc la cité pour les mystères de
l'intérieur au niveau des agents
techniques administratifs il ya le sein
de représentants centrale de il faut
donc au niveau ministère de l'intérieur
quand monsieur valls et a pris ses
fonctions en tant que miss de
l'intérieur à l'époque on a fait une
réunion avec tous les syndicats on était
encore invité à l'époque et et
tout le monde sous le vouvoiement
subissent et ça arrivera donc à ce
fameux syndicaliste donc la cgt a fait
un petit communiqué sur vos qu'on peut
retrouver sur internet
il a dit écoute je suis pourtant manuel
que tu sois là donc c'est le seul qui
l'a tutoyée et il a fait écoute parmi
nous il ya des gens qui mériteraient
d'être préfet quand même par rapport à
l'an bâtissent leur investissement dans
le syndicat donc sur le moment manuel
valls leurs cadres en disant écoutez on
se vouvoie il n'y a pas de tout ça ce
qui était drôle par contre un an après
le même personne passait trop de sous
préfet a été nommé par manuel valls et
le hasard le hasard dont je vous ai dit
que c'était pour services rendus et
parce que vous vous semble insinuer que
la carte politique
permettrait d'avoir de l'avancement
c'est ça
si on caricature en général il ya deux
côtés chez nous il ya majoritaire il ya
il faut qu'ils aient plutôt dit de
gauche parce que ils ont mangé du nca et
l'autre côté la cfe cgc qui est plutôt
de droite quand il ya un gouvernement de
droite bas c'est plutôt la cfe cgc qui
avance et quand c'est plutôt de gauche
et fo qu'avancent les exemples qu'on a
mais après ils arrivent tous aussi à se
mettre d'accord pour le calme dans le
pour qui et pas de vagues je vais donner
un autre exemple c'est que par exemple
delage monsieur delage jean-claude
delage de responsable national bank
d'alliance bon les gardiens de la paix
et rue donc ses responsables d'unité
locale donc cru pour fait c'est un grade
entre guillemets qu'on peut avoir que
quand on occupe une fonction
il occupe aucune fonction de terrain il
encadre personne n'est responsable
syndical donc on a posé la question n'a
pas eu de réponse ceci c'est valable
pour son homologue de force ouvrière sgp
fo unité qu'à la même chose par contre
donc comme c'était la droite qui est au
pouvoir à l'époque où il a eu lui leur
plus si la légion d'honneur
pour quelle raison et à la légion
d'honneur qu'elle fait d'armes il a fait
des collectes ou les jours qui risquent
leur vie qui vont sauver des gens dans
les flammes qui voilà qui sont dans les
attentats a faim ils n'ont pas la légion
d'honneur mu dont une médaille du mérite
quand c'est de temps en temps et lui il
arrive la légion d'honneur donc on se
pose des questions enfin on n'affirme
rien n'ya fait c'est compliqué quand
même d'être policier au 21ème siècle la
population
un petit peu de rancoeur face à la
police la police souffre la police est
de moins en moins a reconnu c'est
compliqué à c est un gardien de la paix
ça gagne combien un gardien de la paix
ça gagne en début de carrière 1600 euros
net net en région par exemple des
avantages en nature logement de fonction
non aux crèches une mutuelle spéciale
est jeune on a des mutuelles police
voilà qui en général le ministère permet
d'avoir des collègues sont détachés pour
s'en occuper donc mais c'est pas un
avantage qu'on a chacun c'est juste un
avantage au niveau de la mutuelle
générale et après au niveau des places
pour le logement il faut demander à la
préfecture donc on passe par la
préfecture donc on est dans un circuit
fonctionnaires général pas spécialement
mais avec quelque chose de façon de
particuliers ou les collègues devant
gerald refusé que les logements
préfecture qui sont proposés sont dans
les zones où ils ont arrêté quelqu'un le
matin j'allais dire compliqué donc c'est
compliqué donc j'arrête s'est refusée
par les gens disent je vais pas le
prendre et dans l'enseignement
territoriale 55 ans mais la pareille en
fait c'est la fonction publique c'est la
même c'est la grille de salaires
fonction publique si je veux acheter un
policier il faut que je lui propose plus
de 1600 euros par mois c'est ça ça s'est
compliqué d'acheter un policier pour
ceux qui sont vertueux après les autres
je ne pourrais pas dire c'est la de la
corruption de la police maintenant à la
corruption c'est-à-dire celles et tous -
les journaux willis et je vais pas dire
le contraire c'est c'est par exemple je
reprends mon frère et ikea où il ya des
fiches stic qui ont été données
pour ces six ayant bien pour en avoir
une fiche du stic il faut payer combien
ben moi je peux pas dire j'ai pas de
prix d'accord
qu'est ce que je peux vous poser que
d'autres comme question un petit peu
touchy
vous avez vous avez assisté à des choses
vraiment dramatique dans votre
profession ou des collusions était
importante
je vais donner un exemple par rapport
aux segments comme ça c'est tous les ans
par exemple gilles binya le medef qui
fait son université d'été
tous les ans il ya la police qui assure
la sécurité
de l'université d'été du medef
tous les ans enfin tout est calme et en
mai puis dans la boucle du coup puisque
j'ai trouvé ma bouche tous les ans les
trophées au travail peut-être peut-être
un moment en fait jusqu'à
deux ans tout est calme maintenant à
prier joël j'ai refait un trait dessus
au map avait affirmé le contraire le
medef demande de passer tous les
intérimaires qui vont avoir officier
pour savoir qu'à qu'ils ont affaire qui
vont embaucher
de façon illégale c'est à dire que ce
que pour passer les fichiers des
fonctionnaires donc une demande
officielle faite
par l'organisateur qui demande à la
préfecture la police nationale jamais
cieux et qui met en face arrive jusqu'à
nous demande de passer aux fichiers avec
comme listings tous les noms des gens
qui travaillent pour le medef sur
l'événement alors que normand pour
passer quelqu'un fléchissent est
encadrée par la loi c'est pour une
enquête administrative pour une
actualisation papier parce qu'on veut
une enquête judiciaire en cours pareil
ou alors quand une personne se déplace
dans un ministère où il ya une
personnalité mais c'est la personne qui
vient dans un lieu sensible j'allais
dire quand cela le medef nous avons mal
à parler à notre hiérarchie nous a dit
que c'est parce que bob des ministres
des places au medef pour leur sécurité
il faut passer devant un officier alors
que légalement c'est que si les gens les
ministres soit vous les personnalités
reçoivent chez eux dans des locaux
sécurisés qu'on le fait donc on n'a pas
eu de réponse pour normand de savoir
quel motif légal on a demandé alors
décrit on n'a jamais eu de nous dire on
fait ça comme ça par oral entre services
c'est normal à l'ancienne à l'ancienne
et
sur place il ya une compagnie de crs qui
est présente nous qui faisons la
protection des personnalités donc quand
ils sont là c'est normal c'est notre
travail par contre qu'on fasse le
filtrage à l'entrée c'est moins normal
jusqu'à une privatisation de la police
mme private aviation de la police on
pourrait dire oui parce que des textes
des circulaires qui sont passés pour
permettre de pas d'acheter un policier
pour un événement j'allais dire pour
assurer la sécurité d'un policier au
loup et peut-être le louer oui j'ai mal
le mot était mal à propos pas le loup
est d'ailleurs non c'est la
séquestration qui met à disposition pour
mais on le loue le policier loubat on a
découvert ça donc il ya ces faits par
certains contrats qu'elle évalue à
chaque fois mais on a un exemple du tour
de france qu'un événement privé et le
tour de france qu'il n'y ait aucun
policier environ 11 euros et un gendarme
environ 12 euros
après il ya le détail combien vaut un
cône en plastique à mettre les motards
ses peluches etc et leparisien fr un
article détaillé sur sa béquille qui
paye là le gardien de la paix ou qui
paie le gendarme c'est une facture qui
élit c'est l'administration qui paie
c'est directement le tour de france
qu'il paye alors c'est l'administration
qui touchent l'argent oui et les
collègues sur le terrain on n'en voit
pas la couleur ils ont pas de
défraiement pour ça on va veiller à des
collègues plus anciens qui m'ont raconté
qu'à l'époque nous assurer des missions
à telgte il a même un petit bonus de
quelques dons de francs à l'époque mais
depuis plus deux il ya plus ça non plus
alors la question qu'on avait posé c'est
que pendant ce temps là est ce que les
citoyen une réduction sur leurs impôts
mieux que la police n'ait pu utiliser la
protection de tous mais pour un
événement privé que pareil on n'a pas eu
de réponses on va changer de sujet on va
aborder la loi de renseignement qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
alward enseignement c'est encore jedir
un peu la communication d'un côté parce
que des éléments par exemple je peux
expliquer que le renseignement
territoriale d'aidé déjà des services
qui sont pas utilisés à leur plein
potentiel lesquelles florence et moi
territoriales on nous à l'heure actuelle
qu'on constate c'est que les gens qui
sont mal intentionnées j'allais dire à
dire des pseudos terroristes ou des gens
qui voudraient commettre un attentat
mais tant ils font plus par internet ils
ont pu des téléphones qui garde en ligne
fixe et environs se met au fond des
kabyles paye en liquide dire que pour
savoir cette information là c'est pas
des gadgets technologiques qui vont
permettre de savoir où ils sont ça va
être forcément dire gestion affaires
coulibaly quand même ils sont passés par
internet pour communiquer oui mais c'est
pas la majorité c'est ce qu'on va
attraper c'est déjà dire les mauvais
les pas organisé et la deuxième qu'au
volet donc par contre c'est le côté des
libertés si qu'on veut nous faire avant
d'une loi pour la protection contre du
terreau faim pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et a pris à toutes les autres
choses qui sont derrière vous votre avis
c'est laurence elle renseigne le
renseignement de terrain c'est la clef
de compréhension du terrorisme c'est à
dire on peut prendre correctement la
température grâce aux renseignements de
terreur sans se barder d'un organe
législatif qui encadre vraiment là
l'aspect numérique
la première étape c'est de se dire on ne
sait pas ce que ça pourrait donner parce
qu'on le fait pas on n'utilise pas le
service à son plein potentiel donc si on
le sait pas on peut pas pourquoi
commencer par faire un nul en disant ça
fonctionne pas ou alors c'est qu'on a
fait en sorte que ça fonctionne pas pour
pouvoir faire la loi est-ce que vous
avez une petite idée de combien ça va
nous coûter cette fameuse et des
estimations que j'ai pu en tête très
cher on peut trouver de l'argent pour
faire les choses qu'on veut bien
business là dedans ce qui est des
prestataires extérieurs qui sont mis par
exemple sur les boîtes noires chez les
opérateurs pensent comme ça vous savez
pas pas la moindre idée je sais juste
que pour les écoutes téléphoniques où il
y avait des relevé il ya des les
opérateurs demandent qui n'ont jamais
été payées d'ailleurs je crois bien
jeudi en direct via une boîte qui est en
difficulté parce que l'état ne payait
pas donc pour vous la loi de
programmation publiée la loi la loi
cazeneuve et contre-productive
ballard et si elle devait intervenir
déjà bien trop tôt parce qu'on n'a pas
tous conviés deuxièmement comme tu as
fait le lapsus il y avait la loi de
programmation militaire qui permet déjà
de parts et les choses dessus qui est
passé aussi de façon anonyme et personne
n'en a parlé à l'époque quasiment alors
va être en deçà surtout le service civil
donc seillière des gens normaux qui
peuvent parler à différents et
militaires qui te regardent ils
qui doivent se taire
donc ensuite c'est aussi le premier de
cette loi c'est que tout est flou et je
fais mien c'est bas il ya dedans il ya
marqué or j'ai pu être exact mais on
pourra s'il ya des attroupements violent
il y aura les intérêts économiques de la
france y aura il ya plein de choses qui
n'ont rien à voir que le terrorisme est
qu'ils n'ont pas défini non une loi
c'est carré on dit voilà il ya tel est
lé mort ça peut arriver devant un juge
et on dit ça fait ça je veux dire quand
quelqu'un vole il sait qu'il va avoir
dans le temps les peines sont de temps
et ça donne conclusion il a fait ça et
c'est ce qu'ils risquent là on ne sait
pas ce qu'on risque parce qu'on sait pas
ce qu'on doit faire ou pas faire déjà à
la base qui fait que tout flou juridique
juridique pardon entraîne un arbitraire
j'ai fait une petite chronologie en
amont c'est que monsieur valls quand il
était ministre intérieur à changer le
code de déontologie chez nous le code
d'oenologie en faisant donc la droite
avaient pris leur faire à l'époque donc
c'était
monsieur guéant mais c'était un
toilettage c'était ont changé de trois
mots c'était pas terrible mais c'était
du toilettage pour fêter les 30 ans là
ils ont tout refait et du coup à
l'intérieur ils ont pris des
dispositions du code de la fonction
publique devichi joue le fonctionnaire
même dans sa vie privée le cocotte de
fonctionnement de vichy a fonctionné la
fonction publique de vichy le
fonctionnaire à l'époque devait même
dans sa vie privée de faire attention à
la à l'honneur l'institution n'ya rien
faire pour aller contre les institutions
moi je travaille de telle heure à telle
heure dans ma vie privée tant que je ne
trahis pas secret professionnel le
secret professionnel sur des affaires
sur des chaussures des noms de personnes
que je pourrais avoir des informations
enfin je suis dans ma vie privée je peux
avoir les opinions et ce que je veux
donc maintenant il ya un an grâce à ce
code de déontologie pas grasse est
ironique un fonctionnaire doit faire
preuve de loyauté de discernement et
tout ça même dans sa vie privée dire que
ce qu'on ankara culture en on a fait un
petit tract dix ans le lundi matin
autour de la machine à café ça va être
sympa je vais pas me raconter mon
week-end de peur qu'on me dise pas
qu'est ce que tu as fait à mais ça tu
avais pas leur à le faire on doit
vérifier son entourage et son entourage
son entourage à qui on parle et c'est
donc on arrive à faire des enquêtes de
proximité directement chez vous quoi
chez nous et en disant surtout le but
c'est pouvoir de sanctionner faire peur
parce que le discernement ce qu'on nous
a expliqué on a une petite formation de
sensibilisation au code de déontologie
et on avait moi j'ai posé la question
disant mais en fait déjà un code de
déontologie vu que c'est limite les
libertés se réduit le prix par une loi
tout ce qui limite les libertés c'est la
loi par décret
on m'a dit on n'est pas là pour juger de
la légalité des expositions ou encore
les dhimmis à l'intérieur mais je suis
tatillon parce que comment faire
respecter les libertés pour les autres
quand j non les a pas respectées
deuxième chose après comment est au
service de la population c'est aussi ça
qu'on a mis en avant ses ya deux
conceptions pour la police nationale et
je crois que c'est là où tout le débat à
quoi sert la police nationale 1c la
police nationale créée par vichy qui dit
au service du gouvernement du patronat
et cetera pour contrôle social de la
population vous pensez vraiment que
cette loi c'est pour
contrôle social de la population je sais
pas si c'est pour ça mais ça peut le
permettre ça peut le permettre et
c'est à dire que tout le monde est
écouté ton poids la loi dans ce sens il
ya qui peut décider dans la loi d'écouté
qui s'est le premier ministre après avis
d'une commission consultative dont
consultatif dire que même si dix dont il
pourra quand même le faire et après
marquer sauf urgence urgence à
l'appréciation n'y a pas de pression
c'est la prestation du premier ministre
qui pourrait dire c'est tout le temps de
l'urgence je mets sur écoute qui je veux
comme je veux et ça peut être servi donc
une fois qu'il ya plus de contrôles
j'aime bien cette dictature de basse
intensité on pourrait dire ça on peut y
arriver en tous les cas on se ramène
vers des gens qui devraient relire
hannah arendt des choses comme ça sur
les origines du totalitarisme
ce que c'est on peut nous dire on le
fera pas on s'en servira pas mais quand
il ya possibilité d'abus un jour il sera
fait ou ne fait pas forcément par les
personnes en place mais notre personne
qui viendra d'art pourra s'en servir
vos collègues
en parle un petit peu entre eux où il
n'y a pas du tout des changes de
critiques sur cette loi est ce que vous
qui entre guillemets la femme de ménage
de la politique étrangère française
c'est à dire qu'on a une politique
étrangère qui est très agressive ou qui
est perçu comme agressif à l'étranger
qui nous amène des répercussions vous
êtes amené à gérer ça
entre vous vous voyez bien que les
signaux faibles de la politique
étrangère française sont au rouge vous
allez être confrontés directement ces
menaces
en première ligne c'est vous êtes le
pompier le pompier mais en bleu
vos collègues ils perçoivent ça commence
alors pour le renseignement
territoriales nous on doit faire
l'environnement d'abord et si jamais on
voit quelque chose on passait à des jets
ici donc déjà nous on n'aura pas la fin
de l'histoire de s'occuper que ce qui
est ici si lionel dans le mans et faire
les repérages déjà quelles formations
pour faire ça l'information s'est on
doit passer le concours de gardien de la
paix ou officiers sûrement le grade de
commissaire on arrive et après on est
pris sur entretien il veut qu'elle vise
avec et le background avant de rentrer
comme gardien de paix moi je travaille
dans le privé avant j'ai fait plein de
petits boulots au niveau des études et
au niveau des tweets j'ai un deug de
droit une licence de sciences politiques
mais c'est pas le cas de tous mes
collègues qui ont faim c'est variable ya
des gens qui ont des bacs plus simples
d'autres qu'on colbac d'hôtes à l'époque
n'avait pas le bac mais karine clôture
général développés qui avait appris par
eux-mêmes donc si à tous les profils du
monde je veux dire il faut savoir est
intéressé par tout curieux à voir au
contact des gens et savoir écrire c'est
les bases du métier d'enseignant génie
c'est vraiment les bases donc pour
revenir à cette loi le fait le fait que
vos collègues pour revenir à ces
questions on perd
on n'en parle pas mais il n'en parle pas
beaucoup ce qu'ont déjà en a l'habitude
et encore plus avec le nouveau code de
déontologie pas deux mais tant qu'on
peut se faire sanctionner pour tout et
n'importe quoi donc du fait vous avez
vraiment été mis au pain
bas ou pas oui puisque je vais donner un
exemple d'un collègue qui avait émis sur
sa page facebook
une page facebook je précise qu il avait
verrouillé pour que ses connaissances
ils y accèdent il avait traité le
président de former président hollande
20 de ces contacts a repris la page
facebook a refait le commentaire
est donc lui il a été en quête
administratif pour dire que ben écoutez
vous manqué de loyauté envers les
institutions vous remettez en cause la
fonction présidentielle la part du
public pas dans le cadre de ses
fonctions il ya pas marqué qu'il est
policier sur sa page facebook mais
l'admistration avaient retenu que
c'était que le ses collègues il ya des
gens qui sache qu'il est là cf qui est
vicié surveille la police pas quelqu'un
qui peut sur les services internes dans
quatre mois on à l'igpn et car il est
veuf carotte c'est ça qui sont en
relation toujours couché puis son
je suis plus aussi songer au ban lors
j'ai su aller voir le jour mais
justement pour un problème de violation
de la vie privée d'un collègue c'est
vrai on est qui était auditionné aussi
pareil parce que par des techniques
d'interception de même par l'agent même
pas ces îles aété fasquelle enquête
s'est mouillé vu un poème de couple safa
même de passer le mot de passe de son
ordinateur etc toujours est il que le
ski a été présenté elle a envoyé des
mails qui lui avait envoyé un échange
pris avec d'autres personnes et les eaux
d'alger peine il a été auditionné sur
ses mails qu'elle avait obtenus de façon
frauduleuse d'accord sur le son
comportement dans sa vie privée qui met
en rien en cause la police sur sur la
loi de renseignement qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous cibler com.com coin comme
point qui pourrait être douloureux par
exemple là j'ai vu récemment que
l'allemagne avait voté parce que
l'allemagne est en train de passer
sensiblement la même chose comme le
québec le canada en allemagne en garde
les informations et les métadonnées
de semaine sur sur notre loi j'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils aient un limite de
temps qu'est ce que vous en pensez
il n'y a pas de limite de temps pour le
moment enfin je l'ait pas vu sinon et la
limite de temps de toute façon je vais
prendre l'exemple du fichier stic qui
doit être mis à jour régulièrement pour
être il est pas mis à jour
pascal pas de personnel pour le faire
ouais mais là ça va être fait par un
algorithme c'était là qu'on va remplacer
la personne qui fait la mise à jour on
va la remplacer par un petit robot est
ce que vous pensez que maintenant la
police est en train de faire sa mutation
et ce sont les robots qui vont avoir le
rôle de policier c'est à dire que vous
nous avez décrit en début d'un franc en
début d'interview qui avait plus de
contacts humains à ce que c'est à vous à
votre avis les prémices de cette
scission de contact entre la police et
la population
c'est la suite de la suite parce qu'on a
déjà eu les contraventions on a eu après
plainte en ligne et en continu de
dématérialiser tout contact avec la
police et tout ce qu'on pourra apporter
à la population et un lien que eelv a pu
la voir ce que tout sera fait par
informatique mais encore s'il ya plus de
contacts avec la population on a beau
avoir tous les objets et gadgets
technologiques on l'aimé où hormis le
fait qu' ils vont pouvoir intercepter
tous les mails qu'ils veulent avec des
mots clés lacie la râpe à personne ça
ciblera dans le tas je trouve que ça un
aspect quand même positif pour une fois
le gouvernement on va écouter les
français et écouter sur quoi on va
écouter leur opinion par rapport à quoi
par rapport à cette fois sur le
renseignement non c'est une boutade dans
la salle pour écouter whisky pense oui
tout âge ah oui d'accord oui on va
arriver à l'année à la nsa la française
comme ça on ils ont ils sauront ce
qu'ils pensent et puis je prends le truc
si jamais les problèmes politiques ils
vont pas faudra changer le peuple va pas
changer le programme
cc c'est quand même lourd de
conséquences que vous dites heures c'est
une haine et ce à la française avec les
abus qui amène et ça a pu effectuer
depuis ses années à ce que vous pensez
que la france sera mieux lotis peut-être
grâce à ses fonctionnaires un petit peu
ce qu'on a dit r61 possibilités d'abus y
en aura forcément il y en ad
malheureusement déjà pour le moment
qu'on peut encore sanctionné là il n'y a
pas deux paliers pas de contrôle en fait
certains n'y a pas de contrôler les
limites je vois pas pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas aller dans le mur nous
aussi tout simplement par exemple on
nous a dit le contrôle du juge c'est
trop compliqué trop compliqué pourquoi
ben c'est ce que nous et 10 et ça marche
pas hays des juges n'ont pas les moyens
de travailler correctement les affaires
s'empilent donnant des moyens à la
justice de pouvoir contrôler le travail
est ce que vous connaissez le budget de
la justice en france non c'est moins que
l'écologie voilà
je lis qu'on est très mauvais au niveau
de l'europe au niveau des procédures au
niveau des entretiens et remy dockstar
mais alors là je ne savais pas oui
justice performante nécessite un budget
performante si on passe les
critères du voile à l'acquisition de
budget pour la justice c'est qu'il ya
peut-être une raison bon ça c'est une
appréciation plus je vais vous poser
deux trois dernières questions
vos préconisations
est-ce que vous avez des conseils à nos
données pour améliorer des choses
pas déjà diffusé l'information de ce qui
va se passer parce que quand le
gouvernement pose une question quelques
personnes pose une question si la
question est mal posée les gens vous
donner la réponse attendue dire qu'on
nous dit une loi contre le terrorisme
vont poser la question est ce que
voulait faire une loi pour lutter contre
le terrorisme réponse est
automatiquement oui enfin moine est un
dangereux terroriste mais sinon c'est
oui maintenant si on dit tout cette loi
va permettre aussi de vérifier votre vie
privée on pourra filtrer vos mails sans
vous le sachiez pouvoir mettre sous
écoute ce sera que dans les mains du
premier ministre et ça va pas lutter
contre le terrorisme quelle sera la
réponse de la population je suis pas sûr
que ce soit la même donc déjà diffusé là
le vrai contenu de cette loi ne plus
utiliser la novlangue voilà et toujours
les vrais mots comme disait quelqu'un ça
ne sert à rien de faire des jeux de mots
parce que les mots n'ont plus de sens
simple mais les mots ont un sens et on
enlevait rajoute de la misère au monde
une dernière question une avant dernière
question
[Musique]
peut-être une dernière question si vous
aviez à l'essai un conseil aux jeunes
générations
à avant ça avance ça avance à vous
conseiller les jeunes générations de
devenir policier
j'allais dire dans l'état actuel des
choses si ils ont un esprit combattant
qui sont prêts à le garder c'est à dire
prêts à subir l'ablation de la rédaction
et quand c'est moi j'ai un copain qui
était en tournée à puy saint ouen
copains d'enfance m'a dit rentre pas bon
je suis rentré
et en fait c'était pas du tout il m'a il
m'avait prévenu que c'était pas l'image
idéalisée que j'en avais qui aurait ni
hiérarchie avec une chape de plomb et
qu'on devrait faire comment on nous dit
et qu'on pourrait pas faire notre
travail pour l'intérêt public est
générale maintenant si on a une volonté
de fer les textes de loi quand tu te
protéger ils n'ont pas encore changé les
textes de loi qui nous permette de faire
notre travail correctement il suffit
d'avoir la volonté ce qui travaille que
sur des coutumes on a toujours fait
comme ça voilà par exemple je reprenais
un exemple très bien et pour ça que je
parle ce soir tranquillement en plus
être syndicaliste c'est que beaucoup de
collègues oublie qu'on nous oppose ce on
a le droit de réserve c'est ce qu'on
nous mêmes et le droit de réserve n'a
jamais été caractérisé les plus drôles
le devoir le devoir réserve pendant
excuse-moi devoir de réserve qui n'a
jamais été qualifiée juridiquement c'est
une invention on comprend bien le secret
professionnel pas donner des infos sur
nous par contre le devoir de réserve à
part critiquer les institutions quand
quelque chose ne va pas je vois pas ce
que ça pourrait correspondre par contre
dans la loi de 83 kif sur la fonction
publique chaque fonctionnaire à un
devoir d'information du public et ça
c'est dans la loi c'est dans un décor
est un devoir d'informer le public corps
comment ça va ce que ça explique
appartient la population ait said on
peut encore changer et quand les
collègues pendant sa en compte devenir
s'avancera déjà beaucoup mieux
si la nounou montre est un petit peu les
questions un peu économiques
géopolitiques géostratégiques on voit on
voit la situation
un petit peu de venir avec ses crabes
partout dans le monde
économiquement parlant et
j'ai une question un peu personnel à
vous poser si la situation se dégrade
que la température de la population
augmente fortement si la fièvre commence
à
parcourir la population à ce que vous
pensez que la police prendra le côté des
manifestants
j'ai ma mère qui soit au service de
l'intérêt général à l'heure actuelle je
ne sais pas
derrière question si vous aviez à aller
c'est un conseil aux jeunes générations
allez voir vos policiers 1 à discuter
avec eux quand vous pouvez encore et
vous verrez que ce n'est pas la même
personne que ce qu'on peut voir à la
télé parce que - toujours les mauvais
exemples ce qui nous casse les pieds
c'est forcément g20 pas de chance ça
arrivait à des gens même à des collègues
qui sont fait contrôler par d'autres
personnes la bêtise et malheureusement
ce qui est plus répandue donc à défaut
que le gouvernement nos collègues et le
courage parce qu'ils sont nuls par les
règlements pas où le colis peuvent pas
aller vers vous venez vers eux un peu
comme ça s'est passé quand il ya eu les
manifestations en soutien à charlie
hebdo tout le monde est venu dans la
police et ça c'était bien parce que les
policiers ont fait confiance et ils ont
pas oublié ce jour-là en tous les cas
qu'il existait au service de qui est ce
que vous pensez pas que la loi de
renseignements c'est légaliser déjà des
pratiques existantes alors ça va
l'église et une partie des pratiques
existantes qui était effectivement pour
moi il est déjà des écoutes
administratives ciblées sur une personne
sur telle personne avec un motif et vous
pouvez contrôler encore la différence
qui va ya voir ça va pas ta contrat
individuel c'est un contrôle de masse
qui va être légalisés qui n'est pas du
tout le cas à l'heure actuelle un
contrôle de la cire conva pouvoir
intercepter tout avec des common
expliqué de telle heure des mots clés
etc qui vont être envoyés sur une
personne avec qu'on connaît ni d'adam ni
d'eve au début et on va commencer à se
ranger sur elle parce qu'elle a fait
telle recherche wali tellement au
téléphone que vous vous allez avoir un
filtrage de masse avec le filtrage des
comportements bassir que les habitudes
est-ce qu il y aura un mot sur internet
il pour le filtre à 10 ans je sais pas
de tien bombe ils vont regarder la
personne pourquoi dix bombes et une
personne par exemple bon je passe à ce
que dans celui du cheval c'est un casque
la personne n'aura rien à voir vieira
par une conversation privée dans le
milieu du cheval mais par exemple
qu'environ mot bombe va être mis dans un
fichier est par exemple dans le manga
jeux vidéo
un shooter pour faire prise de vue
imaginiez-vous si on devait interviewer
un ministre on pourrait dire au
téléphone entre nous on va choquer un
ministre et voilà donc comme ça va être
informatisé ça va être trop leur a donné
des faux positifs
alors on sait pas ce qui aura il y aura
plein de choses y aura tout et n'importe
quoi et surtout un contrôle de masse qui
est individuelle et c'est ça ce qui
change c'est vraiment la grosse
différence un contrôle généralisé plutôt
qu'un contrôle ciblé autant ciblés on
peut encore voir des recours auprès de
la cnil et c'est autant un contrôle de
masse comme on pourrait savoir avoir
recours quelconque parce que même les
organismes de contrôle seront pas conçus
avant de terminer cette interview je
vais vous laisser le micro
j'avais laissé le micro à dissemblances
ce nouveau média qui vient de se créer
sur internet on vous laisse de questions
à poser à monsieur alexandre langlois
syndicaliste travailleurs ans et dumont
territoriale cet om merci alors non à un
média pour les 15 20 ans 45 ans la
génération z et
on s'aperçoit que toute la génération z
donc des 15 25 ans sont absolument pas
au courant de ce que c'est ce que ça
représente réellement la loi de
renseignement donc est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire clairement
qu est-ce qui va décider enfin en quoi
ça consiste alors que la voir dans
l'état actuel des choses en caricaturant
maximum le premier ministre peut mettre
sur écoute qui veut filmer qui veut et
prendre 2 racing moyens filtrer les
mails de kiel et en quoi en quoi c'est
dangereux d'avoir tous ces fichiers là
qu'est ce qu'on peut en faire si ça
tombe dans les mains de quelqu'un de
dangereux qu'est ce qui peut arriver
règne déjà sur les opinions politiques
je veux dire par exemple un gouvernement
qui est un premier ministre qui avait
peu regardé ce que pensent ses
adversaires à savoir comment ils
s'organisent j'arrive politiquement il
un avantage énorme sur les autres après
il peut lui aussi filtrer sur niveau du
mode économique en dix ans bastien telle
société fsi fait sa ba ça donne un
avantage pour ses amis pourraient donner
c'est à dire tant qu a pas de contrôle
de contre-pouvoir pour contrôler la
volonté finalement d'une personne s'il
ya peu avec eux sur des dérives même si
la personne en place le fait pas il y
aura quelqu'un d'autres après lui qui
pourrait le mettre en place et est ce
que les informations que va collecter à
l'état vont être vendus ou est-ce
qu'elles pourront peut-être phrases qui
vont se livrer un jeu comme ça ou pas
alors ça on sait pas par contre on a
déjà un précédent pour le fichier des
cartes grises ils ont déjà vendu 10 à
des sociétés privées en prétextant que
ça allait plus vite dans les prés les
préfectures était surchargée à l'époque
on avait fait un petit article car ça
nous a pris sauf le figaro ce qui était
amusant et met donc du coup des sociétés
privées se dire que ça fait deux choses
l'une un dire que les gens qui ont accès
à un service public normalement
préfecture pour l'heure qu'à te brise
ils doivent attendre plus longtemps des
gens qu'ils vont payer pour avoir accès
dans une société privée à deux vitesses
à deux vitesses en fonction du site de
l'argent qu'on a voilà on n'a plus tous
égaux devant le service public deuxième
chose c'est que les fichiers vendus aux
aubois de priver pas une fois qu'elles
ont elles ont un avec les adresses les
noms des gens un peu vouloir vendre
peuvent en faire ce qu'ils veulent même
si elles signent une charte on sera
jamais ce qui a été fait derrière donc
on a déjà un précédent pour les cartes
grises tôt qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
pourront faire par la suite
alexandre langlois je vous remercie
un plaisir
[Musique]